let's get more now on the breaking news
that former girls allowed singer sarah
harden has died at the age of 39 after
being diagnosed with breast cancer
record producer pete waterman is on the
phone and he joins us now thank you very
much indeed for your time here on sky
news this afternoon now this news has
come such a shock his devastating news
what's your reaction to this
well i knew she was obviously very
poorly but this is a bit of a shock home
blimey it's uh
yeah i mean
for me
i remember going around the house during
popstar's arrivals and batching on the
bed when i told her she was
going to be part of the group you know
and um
it's just it's just tragic so young's
you know it's a brighter future
you can't really get your granny can you
it's just so young really
and pete i can hear that shock in your
voice and the shock also is the fact
that she was only diagnosed just last
year
and then this has happened so quickly
yeah i mean i knew i knew that she was
obviously diagnosed and i knew she was
poorly
but you know this same age we just
modern medicines are so good and we hear
so many positive uh outcomes it's
really quite shocking when that goes the
opposite way really in people so young
this is just uh
it's i feel so sorry for our family and
the friends it must be you know it's
tough this is a this is a tough thing to
bear you know
and you were one of the judges on the
programs that actually brought her to
fame where we were able to see her
talents of course as girls allowed what
was it about her that drew you to her
and the other judges to her
well she was a
a really
fantastically bubbly as i say i remember
going to a house
in manchester to tell her that she was
uh been picked to go into the group
and i mean she ran upstairs uh and was
jumping on the bed with joy and you know
the film of me
in her bedroom jumping up and down for
she was an excitable young kid she was
typical of what what it was all about
excitement you know
just real enthusiasm so
that's what that's not that long ago
that's probably what 2003 2000 of what
we're talking less than 20 years ago
and pete i remember watching those
moments on tv i remember watching girls
aloud forming sitting there glued to the
tv
and you can see the chemistry between
those people you can also see the
talents just beaming out of them beaming
out of sarah
so was always i have to say and this is
not because of today's news sarah was
one of my favorites sarah was a lovely
lovely person i remember as i say a mom
at a house they were overjoyed and
during the series
you know we spent a lot of time just
talking everything through
uh
it wasn't easy the whole competition
thing sort of made us and them
but not with sarah sarah was just a
delightful young kid she was great
enthusiasm full of life this is a
tragedy